killed him he turned them all
you know this done what's up ladies and
gentlemen welcome back to talking
thrones once again I am joined by gray
area and today we are gonna finish our
predictions for Jon Snow this was a
three part series so if you did not see
the other two videos about Jon make sure
you go check those out first then come
back to this one this will be our last
installment for our jon snow prediction
so let's just pick up right where we
left off the last thing I asked gray
area was what it was going to take to
actually be able to defeat the night
king if Jon does ride ragle which I
think he will I hope he does and I think
he's gonna need to because we saw how
easily Viserion was taken down and if
Daenerys is dragons are just up flying
around in the sky by themselves and you
have the night King on his dragon
attacking them and possibly all of his
white Walker lieutenants chucking
javelins at him they could probably take
the other ones down just as easily so I
would like to think both of those
dragons need a rider to prevent that
from happening and it would be better
because Jon could actually control the
dragon and have more direct dragon fire
placed in the locations that they need
it other than just having the dragon fly
around and just light fire wherever so
do you think that would be enough to
stop the night king or what Jon need a
sword like a light bringer or something
else magical to actually be able to stop
the night king or do you think it's
gonna have to come down to us seeing
another pack to be made between the
people and the others I do kind of think
they're gonna need everything I don't
think it will be enough I think it is
gonna come down to all the legends as
skewed and mixed up as they are they're
all connected to the children of the
forest so I definitely think they have a
huge part to play that hasn't been
foreshadowed yet and we know the last
hero wasn't able to stop the fighting
during the long night until he was able
to find their children on the forest yes
and like all of the across the Narrow
Sea like all of those legends are like
in some way related to the children of
the forest it all ties to the children
of the forest or they don't call it the
long night across the Narrow Sea they
call it a darkness or a coldness so you
think there is chosen on the forest
stole alive yes definitely what do you
think they would be the gods I the Isle
of faces so you think we'll definitely
see something go down there and not just
in the North so so I don't know I feel
like every battle that's ever been
fought has that meant anything was in
the Riverland so I feel like this show
needs to end things in the Riverlands
and we also had that news that
Corvette's castle where they filmed
Riverrun mm-hmm is gonna be in season a
they like they've seen some film and
action going on there so the Riverlands
has a big part to play also there's a
lot of foreshadowing with it as far as
the books go with Daenerys riding to the
Trident like Rhaegar the usurpers hosts
armored and ice and her bathing them in
Dragon Fire absolutely and I've been
wondering about the children of the
forest because I felt like there was
definitely still some more but in the
show it seemed like the ones that died
in the cave leaf and the other ones they
made it seem like those were the only
ones or at least the last ones left and
ever since then I've been wondering if
we're gonna ever see them again and then
I've also been wondering if we
technically still need the children or
the forest because bran has now become
pretty much the ultimate green seer he's
almost the most powerful one besides the
night king who I think is still more
powerful than bran as of right now but I
think bran will eventually overpower the
night King in the end so taking all that
into consideration I'm wondering if
there actually will be more children of
the forest left in this show and like
you said I think if there is then they
would have to be at the gods eye which
is pretty much one of the only places we
haven't seen of important
yeah that that's where they would have
to be but you make a good point you know
about brain because now that he's a
green seer and he knows how to access
the weirwoods when the children died
they become a part of the trees
everything they knew becomes a part of
the trees yeah definitely and we have
samwell tarly which we talked about in
our brain stock video I think Sam will
pretty much be the one that's kind of
like a stand-in for brand figuring out
how to learn all this stuff that he
still needs to figure out because when
bran was basically in his training
inside the cave it was to children of
the forest and the Bloodraven who was
being very subtle with what they wanted
brain to know but now that they're gone
Sam will pretty much stand in for being
brands almost like teacher with showing
him what happened in the past where he
would probably need to look to figure
out how to start the night king now that
the children are gone and the north
unless we see them and the gods I like
you say we possibly could yeah it's a
possibility but I think it's probably
more of a possibility like what you're
saying is that they're just gonna use
brain as like a representation of the
children absolutely when all this takes
place and we finally get this ultimate
scene with John and whoever he has left
on his team and bran and Sam against the
night king and it's that final showdown
how do you think that's gonna end just
in your guess I know no one really knows
but just in your prediction and what do
you think it's gonna actually take to
end this fighting would it have to be
then I can getting killed or a pact I
think it's gonna have to be the night
king getting killed or the night king
losing every soldier that he has because
before they were never completely
destroyed they just fought them good
enough to keep them to send them fleeing
to the lands of always winter so I think
it will probably be something more along
those lines of them just not defeating
them but defeating
enough to where he can he knows he can't
win and he leaves and retreats yeah I
could see something like that too if
they don't end up killing him but for
some reason I feel like at least that's
how they're gonna end it in the show
it's probably gonna be this big huge
spectacle with Jon Snow in the night
King either sword fighting it out or one
the dragons fighting it out one verse
one what you know you've talked about
before I feel like it's gonna come down
to that and I think they actually need
to kill than I King this time so that
this cycle doesn't continue in the
future eight thousand years later again
or whatever for them to finally end this
threat they're gonna have to completely
destroy all of the others yeah I mean
that's what I want to happen I yeah I
want to see that's what I want to see
happen and I don't disagree that that's
possible but I like wonder what is it
gonna take for John to be able to kill
him like I don't feel like a regular
just Valyrian steel will kill him
or just kill I think it's gonna be a lot
more complicated than it I don't think
he could be killed by the same weapons
that the white walkers can be killed
with because we've seen them die by
dragonglass and Valyrian steel but we
know the night King is more powerful
than them and he was created with
dragonglass so I don't think dragonglass
would be able to stop him it would have
to be either a dragon or some kind of
crazy sword like light bringer there's
really not a whole lot of other evidence
that point to a different weapon
stopping him other than a dragon or a
light bringer type sword
I don't think fire really affects him
I'm wondering if direct dragon fire
raining on him one o EV drogue on eating
him that would be crazy
oh man it'd just be like crunching on an
ice cube I've be fed be hilarious it
seems like bran is the
that he's afraid of because he didn't
want brands to become the three-eyed
Raven he wanted to kill bran
yeah he knows bran is gonna be his
biggest threat and he he didn't kill
John he had all these opportunities to
kill John and he didn't absolutely he
could have killed Johnny hardhome he
could have killed John and um beyond the
wall yeah he coulda fur one of those
javelins until he eventually hit him and
he could have like when John fell into
the lake he was there when he fell into
the lake yeah he had all of his men's
right the night Kings went got Vissarion
wonder why he didn't go and get John I
don't know it's really weird yeah a lot
of people have been wondering that
question because it does seem like he
knows John in a way that John doesn't
quite understand yet and even when uh
beric Dondarrion pointed at the night
king and he said you take him down and
the rest will fall and john was like you
don't understand almost like he knows
it's gonna be a little more than that
so there's definitely something going on
between the Starks and the night king
which we know in the books the night's
king who this character is based off of
is a stark so I'm wondering if the show
is gonna add something to that
to this character in the show with some
kind of a stark connection I do feel
like that I feel like once Sam and bran
put their minds together and are trying
to find information out for John we're
gonna find out a lot more we're gonna
find out more than we ever knew about
the White Walkers
whether it's book cannon or not we're
gonna find out the who what when where
why everything do you think that will be
the final WTF moment the truth about the
night King I should say I think it has
potential to be the final WTF moment but
I kind of think the final WTF moment is
gonna have to do with Cersei
hmm yeah could that's actually goes into
my next question assuming John survives
this war against the night Cain how will
John and Daenerys deal with Cersei how
do you think that's gonna play out after
they take care of the others assuming
they do I don't think he's gonna have to
take care of Cersei I think Cersei is
gonna take care of herself so I've said
before like Cersei has a lot of
parallels with the Mad King and also
make or the cruel now a lot of people
say that Jaime is gonna kill Cersei but
the Mad King sword in the back and all
that stuff so that's very possible but I
also think that she could kill herself
do you think she would do that by
blowing up the Great Hall or just
killing herself like we saw when the
Battle of the Blackwater was going on
and she was gonna drink a potion like
that so maybe we're the cruel was found
with his wrists cut and like the Iron
Throne cut him so I think Cersei could
die like that like some kind of suicide
on the Iron Throne like she'll be found
dead on the Iron Throne when Jon comes I
think we are gonna see Cersei get to a
level of desperation that we've never
seen her get to before because her last
bit of hope is this baby that she says
she has in her belly and she has your
own Greyjoy who is allegedly picking up
the golden company for her right now but
a lot of people believe the golden
company will eventually break their
contract with Cersei in order to swear
their fealty to one of the Targaryen
xand if that happens
Cersei would no longer have Jaime she
would no longer have her her
reinforcements in the golden company her
Lannister numbers have to be pretty
small after the field of fire and I
believe she's gonna lose the baby so
when all this happens in Cersei realizes
she truly has nothing left we're gonna
see her do something that she's never
done before she's gonna be extremely
desperate and almost capable of anything
yeah she is and
she's gonna be lower than she was when
she did that walk of shame like she's
gonna be lower than that cuz she's she
doesn't have her kids anymore she
doesn't have anyone anymore she's
isolated and she's gonna be out of her
mind and when she's gonna feel those
went once the night Kings defeated him
John has to deal with her set that's
assuming that he's gonna deal with her
after the night king and she's gonna
feel like the walls closing in on her
and she's gonna I don't think I think
she's gonna take her own life
yeah I like the way he said that she's
definitely gonna feel those walls
closing in on her cuz all she's really
gonna have left if the golden company
does betray her and break that contract
and go north she won't have anything
left but a few Lannister men and I don't
even know if you're on would still be
willing to stick around after that
because at some point he would have to
realize that he's on the losing side he
would eventually leave her because uh
even in season seven when Cersei was
talking to the representative from the
iron bank he was talking about how her
ships that she had wasn't hers they were
the iron borns and Cersei was like
you're on Greyjoy swears fealty to me in
the guy from the golden company was like
basically yeah but for how long exactly
so yeah I could see her getting to that
point that desperate point to where she
feels like she has no other way out yep
I can definitely see the happening and I
would actually a that's how actually how
I would like her to go do you think we
will see the throne room looked like it
did in Dany and brands vision will we
see the throne room look like that in
the end I do think so and um I think you
made the best point when you said
because a lot of people were saying it
was wildfire and how wildfire would like
just destroy it yeah this looks like
it's not destroyed it's only the roof is
destroyed so that definitely looks like
dragon fire yeah it does because it's
only in the roof though the ground and
the throne and the pillars and
everything else seemed to be intact and
it just looks like it
a fire from above right so it's hard to
say is it the night Kings Dragon or is
it one of Daenerys dragons if the night
Kings all the way in King's Landing then
they're like effed if the night King
makes it to King's Landing but I'm
assuming Winterfell was pretty much ran
over yeah or he didn't go to Winterfell
he bypassed it yeah which I doubt I
think because of everything we know from
filming he there's definitely gonna be
something going on at Winterfell mm-hmm
and that would mean that storm's end is
left storm's end will still be left
because I think that's more southern
than King's Landing but also Dragonstone
will still be standing the children of
the forest carved those paintings in the
cave of dragonglass at Dragonstone but
there's like nowhere woods at dragon
stones dragon son is basically like a
rock so what were children of the forest
doing at Dragonstone I'm guessing the
only reason why they would have went
there is just to get the dragon glass
and they probably just love it who's
they probably just left all those
paintings so when people found it they
would eventually realize what that stuff
down there was needed for what was
eventually gonna come true I find it
hard to believe that the knight King is
just gonna come and sweep through each
Kingdom because if he's if he's at
King's Landing that means he's went
through the whole entire north he's went
through the Riverlands and he's at
King's Landing yeah and that would
either mean John and Danny and everybody
died or they had to retreat a hell of a
lot farther south than they probably
intended on and that means the knight
king's army grew a hell of a lot bigger
yeah that would probably mean everybody
at karhold the dread for white Harbor
went away I mean everywhere from east
water
yeah pretty much every building from
Eastwatch to King's Landing he could
potentially turn into his army and if
that happens I don't see them when
I just don't know if they would be able
to stop him if they allowed him to gain
that much momentum they're gonna need to
stop him before that I think yeah I
definitely agree do you think John and
Danny will be able to win two wars one
against the night king and potentially
one against Cersei yes a lot of people
will say that Daenerys is Miss Anissa
and John is azure high and John's gonna
the sacrifice Daenerys and sacrifice go
smella so i do not think i think they
are going to be alive
I know 100% that John isn't dying
Daenerys I'm like 80% sure she's not
dying when you think about it the Song
of Ice and Fire is John but the Song of
Ice and Fire is also Daenerys as well
the the story is about them and I can't
see them - not getting at least a
bittersweet ending I agree with you
about John I do believe John will
survive although for a long time I
didn't I thought John would eventually
do some kind of sacrifice to ensure that
everybody else would survive but now I'm
more leaning to the side that John will
live and I think Danny will die I think
if one of them dies it's gonna be Danny
in some way and there's a lot of
different theories going around about
why whether that's nice Aneesa her dying
during childbirth the night King killing
her while she's on drogon I mean there's
a lot of different ways that that could
happen other than like a sacrifice for
herself - but I think if it's one of
them it would be Danny I feel like if I
had to choose between them - who was
gonna die I would say it was it was her
she's yes cuz I'm a hundred percent sure
that John Snow is not dying I hope
you're right I was also a hundred
percent short this is just a disclaimer
I was also a hundred percent sure that
he wasn't gonna die in season five and
he died yeah but he came back so you was
he was right and wrong I guess
but not for long okay so I do want to
ask something else kind of pertaining to
that what do you think will happen after
the night King and Cersei are dealt with
who would then be in control after that
would it be John or Danny we know John
has the the rightful claim because he is
a legitimate Targaryen but what John
allow Danny to keep that title or do you
think they would rule together or would
there be an entire committee how do you
think that would play out after these
wars are finished John and Daenerys will
be tired of fighting tired of conquering
like George is a very is he's a fan of
Tolkien and he's inspired by the Lord of
the Rings we know that there's a lot of
the Lord of ring Lord of the Rings stuff
in here and I feel like John is Frodo
from Lord of the Rings like he's gonna
be too damaged from everything that's
happened to him so far to want to rule
the Seven Kingdoms I don't feel like
he's gonna care about that the only way
he's gonna rule the Seven Kingdoms
is if it's imperative that he does if he
doesn't have to or if he could put
someone else in power then I feel like
that's what he would do I ultimately
think that the best king for Westeros
would probably be Tyrion or Davos yeah
those are two good candidates but I
don't think it'll be John and I don't I
also think that Daenerys is going to be
I don't think she's gonna care about it
either she probably won't although
that's what highly motivates her still
is wanting to claim her power in her
position as the queen of the Seven
Kingdoms but ultimately in the end after
all this is over I think she would
realize that for the wheel to actually
be broken she can't have it both ways
and her still be the queen of the Seven
Kingdoms but break all those old
traditions - at the same time they would
need to come up with some other way to
basically distribute the power instead
of having one
person control everything in Westeros
exactly and that's kind of where I'm at
that's kind of I kind of agree that she
is a spoke on the wheel so it has to be
broken for it to be broken if she has to
as she can't be the queen either yeah
definitely though maybe that may be the
ending will be that they move away from
like this feudalism society they get out
of it and kind of get into like a
democratic democratic republic or
whatever and have an election I think so
and I think John would probably help
influence
Danny's decision and wanting to do that
too and we know Tyrion already kind of
mentioned that last season with about
how the Ironborn do do their electing
and stuff like that so it's kind of
already being put in place in Tyrion
also tried to remind her that you might
want to break the wheel now but you have
to put things in place to ensure that it
would stay broken in the future earlier
in the video and part one I asked you if
you believe Daenerys was pregnant with
John's child which we both agreed 100%
she is pregnant by the end of all of
this do you think she will actually give
birth to this child yes there will be a
John and Daenerys baby and she will give
will give birth to it what do you think
they would name it a boy or a girl both
either one I would like to think it was
a boy they would name it Eddard uh-huh
if it's a girl they would name her Liana
would they give it the Targaryen name
and the reason why I want to ask that
real quick is because something we both
made videos about and we both talked
about is what other Starks gonna do with
having an error in the future because
none of them have any kids right now
John's last name isn't Stark what are
they going to do to ensure that there is
a stark and Winterfell in the future
yeah
John would have to give his baby the
stark name or the shows gonna have to
end with some type of imply that Sansa
or Arya will eventually be in some kind
of a relationship and have a kid
yeah um you know that's kind of crazy
because if you don't name it Targaryen
the Targaryen line guys as well yeah
that's where it's a real dilemma because
the both of those lines are on the verge
of extinction if there is no error
they hyphenate the last name Targaryen
Stark that would be pretty cool but I
don't know if they'd do that in those
times yeah I'm not sure I'm trying to
now that you say that I'm trying to
think if somebody ever carried two last
names in the books and I don't really
remember ever seeing it like that
but I could be wrong could be in the
history and lore or something well you
know they did they made those branches
like Karstarks that's right yep so we
could see a star garyun or something
like that would say which a lot of
people think and would like because I
know that's been like a kind of like a
running joke or like a running thing you
would see on a t-shirts Targaryen so
mm-hmm
yeah bringing up Karstark that's a good
point we could see something like that
to where it takes on both names and can
you imagine the the family that would be
born from that kid of having all
Targaryen and stark jeans like I'd be a
hell of a that'd be a nice line yeah I
like that idea
and I kind of would like to see them do
something like that and if they're gonna
break the wheel they could start doing
that and giving it to like a hyphenated
type name yeah definitely but if I had
to choose between Targaryen our stark
stark all day name name its dark like if
you have to pick I'm picking stark
absolutely I would too and I think this
is a very good place to end the video I
think we've pretty much covered every
topic with Jon Snow at least most of the
big things that I
think we could see with him and for that
I thank you for joining me gray I
appreciate everyone who is listening to
this video and liking this video and
leaving comments I really appreciate
that and I want to thank gray area for
joining me
thanks a lot gray I really enjoyed
talking to you about John snow thanks I
appreciate you for bringing me on your
channel I love when we have these
discussions because we're actually
pradhan going off a script we're just
talking and that's when great things
happen absolutely it was a lot of fun
and I want to thank everybody for
joining me I want to thank all of our
patreon supporters for supporting both
of our channels and I hope to see
everybody in the next one bye
[Music]
you
[Music]
[Music]
Oh